Buenos días ha sido un fin de semana muy
intenso en el parlamento europeo en que
el juez ha imputado a cuatro personas
entre ellas la vicepresidenta y
eurodiputada griega Eva kyli por hechos
muy graves como corrupción blanqueo de
capitales y también y también por
corrupción se trata de un asunto muy
grave según las instituciones europeas
Eva Kylie fue detenida también su pareja
un asistente parlamentario así como
también un antiguo eurodiputado que
ahora mismo trabaja en una ong a favor
de los Derechos Humanos el juez imputa
estos delitos en que se cree que Qatar
pagó cuantiosas sumas de dinero a estos
miembros para influir positivamente a
favor de
Qatar se trata de un escándalo mayúsculo
para la institución la presidenta de la
institución Roberta mensola ya ha dicho
que trabajará conjuntamente con la
justicia Así que el jefe de la
diplomacia europea también josep borré
ha asegurado que es un asunto muy grave
si se confirman los
Esther que sigue en todo este proceso
Sí hoy todos los ojos estarán puestos en
la eurocámara o ya habrá un discurso de
la presenta del parlamento europeo
Roberta mechole en la apertura de la
sesión todos los diputados están
reunidos hoy en estrasburgo en que
también se espera que haya un debate
para analizar esta cuestión este caso de
corrupción se daba la circunstancia
además que esta semana está previsto que
se votara a favor de la liberalización
de visados con Qatar de momento se
espera que se pueda rechazar para que
vuelva otra vez a la comisión
parlamentaria y analizar todos estos
hechos